c'était tellement c'est tellement ça il
avait raconté non je plaisante j'ai fait
du cinéma pour une fois je peux vous la
raconter vite fait parce que je sais que
vous êtes tous friands d'anecdotes
j'ai tourné un film une fois
je vous ai sur le tournage a duré huit
heures je jouais le rôle d'un
présentateur télévisé
je suis donc à mon journal pendant 8
heures ils m'ont fait faire du jt quand
le film est sorti au cinéma j'ai fait
venir toute ma famille est là je
découvre le montage je vois le méchant
rentrer dans la pièce je ne me vois pas
il allume la télé donc on me voit mieux
nos voix à 15 m dans un corps ne me
reconnais pas et là on me voit faire
bonsoir et lui fais ta gueule et il est
allé copain à côté qui sont gênés quand
même temps qu'ils osent pas te regarde
c'est pas mal j'en ris